and they we used to call them sausage
bags okay so they have compactors in the
buildings that literally compact these
things and then the guys not the ends
and they're you know anywhere from 3
feet to you know four or five feet long
and could somebody have put a body in
one you think oh yeah you could have put
a body in any one of them I ain't
looking yeah that other dude is I'm not
I could give a damn yeah that dude
[__] I would tell people all the time
the minute you want to do that just put
it in a bag I ain't looking
oh that dude's selling femur on ETS
exactly you know yep half price dud out
there yeah y that dude's out there
[__] slanging Shin Bones on on
eBay but D so somebody could put a body
in one of those bags zip it out to the
garbage guy you never know and the mafia
used to be involved in it right that's
why they were in it well when you
brought up bodies like that's the one
thing on stand Island those are the
midst the tals they my stepf father God
rest of the Soul used to work out there
he was a tractor operator mhm M and he
said that cars used to come in pimped
out Lincoln and they would just all turn
around and the car used to go up to the
top of the hill never see it again Wow
Car just disappear person disappear they
pull out see you later fellas that was
it it's the devil's ocean baby the
landfill yeah there's a lot of stories
out there with that landfill uhhuh I
wonder I wish God would just tell us how
many bodies are in that landfill
sometimes I pray sometimes that I wake
up with the number in my
head so a way to get a if you want to
get if you decided to decease somebody
or kill somebody I don't like to use
that term but make somebody be dead
immediately in front of you let's say
that uh in New York City you could put
them into the shoot in your building the
trash Sho well I wouldn't do that like
that's a little much but if you had you
know access to the compactor okay then I
think it's different but if you're going
to to shoot a d 13 flights down I mean
somebody's about to hear you there's got
to be some blood you know dink dink dink
dink going down somebody can hear a
wrist watch wall ex yeah yeah somebody's
watch is going to connect and
something's going to Ping in and you
know how that goes right so if you could
get the body down to the compactor
there's a chance it could just be thrown
out in one of those sausage bags gone
wow did you ever feel like did you ever
get a weird feeling or premonition like
you're driving the truck home like could
there have been a body in there and you
have no idea it's some point whenever
that's you're dumping it you would have
seen something listen you you definitely
think you could get a feeling you know
if somebody comes out and says something
you're like oh maybe this dude just
whack somebody right you know his wife
ain't healthy right now she's probably
in this bag right like I'll throw it in
oh yeah but no I never I had
one these two guys came out of the house
one day hysterical crying oh yeah I'm
like what the [__] happened you know
what now and we were in that kind of
neighborhood in St Island and I'm like
all right what's up our dog died I'm
like oh oh my gosh bring it to get
cremated what the why you telling me
they trying to cut Corners couple gay
dudes trying to cut Corners could we
throw it in the truck I'm like [__] and
I'm a I'm a dog owner at the time I'm a
dog lover next thing you know with on
the bed dude a yellow lab this thing had
to be 100 lb oh and they both grabbed
they were crying no they it was on the
bed they got rid of the bed the toys the
[__] was still lined up like he was just
playing and then just
dead like and they're like okay and just
launched him into the back of the truck
I'm like I told my my partner I'm like
dude you got to I can't cycle that up
man yeah like I was like oh [__] so it's
like you would get the feeling if
somebody was like oh yeah can I throw
this bag in like where's your
wife I don't hear you know I heard y'all
fighting last week about garbage and you
know and so what then you tell a guy hey
you pressed the button I ain't pressing
it this yeah I just you know in that
case I was like dude you I told my
partner and he was just he didn't give a
[__] he's like hey all right yeah I was
like I'll sell his collar in an hour
yeah give a [__] that big usable yeah
here's a one right here garbage man
saves kittens from trash Jesus yeah I
mean shaa toad probably doing this you
be shocked man yeah anybody ever triy to
put a baby in the garbage bro so I won't
tell anybody if you tell and I'll know
if you're lying too all right so I had
like a year on a job got hurt sure I had
this s uh shoulder done surgery so they
do like this mail carrying thing where
you bring go you know the mail to like
like Lower East garages so you go to
like the main area pick up all the mail
you give it to the each garage so I pull
into one of the garages I forget
somewhere in Manhattan 2 I think oh so
it's a job you can still work even
though you're injured exactly so I'm
like in rehab you know coming back you
know trying to get my arm back together
and next thing you know I walk in the
garage everybody's in tyvec suits white
tyac you know covered head to toe I'm
like I got a T-shirt and pants on I'm
like what the [__] going on here [__]
this a Shriners meeting right so there's
a garbage truck emptied out on the floor
cuz they got a phone call that a girl
put a baby in a corner basket
oh I I just I don't even know if they
found it I just you know nobody puts
baby in a cornerback
no
nobody